"Wednesday" has been the talk of TV
Twitter lately, but not always for
a good reason. So what's really going
on with the sudden Tim Burton backlash?
After debuting on November 23, the Netflix
series managed to rack up positive reviews
and record-breaking streaming numbers,
with more than 341 million hours watched
in its first week on the app, according to
Netflix. No other English-language TV show
has been able to bring in those results for
the streamer over the course of its first week.
The supernatural coming-of-age
story follows Jenna Ortega's.
Wednesday Addams as she adjusts to life at
Nevermore Academy, a Vermont-based reform
school for other peculiar outcasts like
herself in the fictional town of Jericho.
On the surface, "Wednesday" is a show that seems
innocent and fun, with a familiar premise based
on "The Addams Family" characters and franchise.
However, there's something that many fans have
found extremely wrong with the spinoff, which
is getting talked about a lot as of late.
For some "Wednesday" viewers, it feels like the
creative team, including executive producer and
director Tim Burton, chose to cast Black actors
as the show's main antagonists. As a result,
fans have been taking to social
media to voice their outrage.
One user tweeted,
The casting choices that viewers are
most upset about are New York-born actor
Joy Sunday — who plays resident mean
girl Bianca Barclay at Nevermore — and
Hollywood newcomer Iman Marson, who
plays Lucas Walker, a local bully.
Walker's family runs the show's fictional
Pilgrim World. His father, Noble Walker,
is the mayor of Jericho and owns
the colonizer-themed theme park.
"It takes a special kind of stupid to devote
an entire theme park to zealots
responsible for mass genocide."
It's easy to see how casting Black actors to
run such a place could be considered tone-deaf,
which is exactly what people
are calling it on social media.
Self-described "Anti-Racism
Consultant" Jon Cornejo tweeted:
A lack of diversity in Tim Burton's projects
has been an issue over the years. After making
the 2016 fantasy flick "Miss Peregrine's
Home for Peculiar Children," Burton was
called out for having a predominately white
cast, with Samuel L. Jackson being one of
the only non-white stars — and serving as an
antagonist. Burton told Bustle at the time:
Jackson, himself, called out Burton for
his lack of diversity, telling Bustle: